bark bark like the fults in your body to
create another hole Christian you smells
oh like sex someone's going to pounce on
my dick someone want eatting my wolf
wolf [__] good day guys this is um
Christian you otherwise known as Dean
and I'm here with BuzzFeed and today oh
boy I'm going to be reading your first
tweets I'm going to say I've never done
this before I've seen it seen it
everywhere and I've never wondered how I
would react to this I'm actually curious
myself
honestly so I'm going in goodness
already I just be horny and Love
Christian you I just be horny I hope you
calm down a little oh boy I love you too
on to the next if they get dpie in to
read first tweets I might have to delete
my account well this wasn't so bad was
it I mean I hope you don't delete your
account goodness are you horny too no
I'm I'm kidding I'm Jesus Christ I
cannot okay so it's like this this is so
interesting I've never actually sat down
and read those tweets that I kind of
like this my goodness yeah but please
don't delete your account oh DP in could
fold me like an origami and I would
thank him for folding you like an
origami that sounds terrible goodness I
would hate to do that that that's almost
like a contortionist isn't it but oh boy
I'm sure there's like a a different
meaning to this it sounds almost a
little sexual doesn't it it is oh it is
okay makes sense all right I'm so sorry
I'm so bad at this um it's very visual
folding someone like an origami that's
doesn't sound too nice unless you're
really flexible Christian you posting
that shirtless video is why I decided to
pull my life together once again I'm
quite confused about this one um does
that mean I kind of slap some sense into
you with that shirtless video is why I
decided to put my life together once
again is that a good thing or a bad
thing oh it's a good thing okay I
thought like when she saw that they
didn't like it so they were like I got
to get focused again I got to get my
life back together I was living under a
rock I did not know Christian you and DP
were the same person you know what I
don't blame you I like DP I for for the
music and Christian knew for his hot
sexy goofy awkward self goodness I mean
I am the same person but I guess well on
stage I'm you know DP Ian people
probably know me like that but you know
I am Christian you and I am pretty goofy
but I'm so glad you think that and how
do you feel now that it's the same
person oh man I'm this is this is crazy
I just I'm just don't know how to this
is like the first time I'm reading any
of these so this person just remembered
Christian Yu is a Virgo man you know
what I'm I like astrology it's quite
accurate
what does that mean and two breaking
heart emojis what does a vgo man mean
break oh is that what it is I break two
hearts oh my
goodness really I hope I don't break
anyone's heart I've had my heart broken
a few times is that what that means it's
pretty accurate but I do only have one
heart okay this next one is a is a bit
of a task this message is to
dprian ar ar ar woof woof ar ar ar bark
bark that is all # tweet clo I believed
I was meant to simulate a wild animal
noise I just realized what this was at
some of our shows sometimes people start
barking is that kind of like hurting
your horn at somebody okay I love it I
love it
jeez I love this I I just cannot my
goodness I could just read this all day
I need to make DPR Ian my baby girl oh
my goodness I've heard it all people
call me daddy mommy and now baby girl
come here pretty boy and sit on my lap
yes ma'am
I'll gladly oblige uh if someone said
that to me in real life I don't know how
I'd react I think I'll say okay I I'll
be right there so thank you thank you
sweetie I'll be on your lap pretty soon
oh goodness call me oldfashioned but I
was raised to serve DPR he got me there
I clean the dishes and cooking food I do
whatever he says because he is my
husband and he makes the rules around
the house he owns me if he ever cheats
on me it's because I was lacking I feel
so bad all of a sudden I don't know why
no don't don't ever feel bad you're not
lacking I don't know why it feels so
personal right now goodness I can do the
dishes I can do the food I'm a pretty
good cook myself and no they definitely
not lacking and if I have a cheat which
I won't by the way I'm not that type of
person it's because I screwed up so I'm
sorry goodness we I read a whole story
it feels like I'm in a movie right now
STFU which is shut the up no one talks
to me I saw sweat trickling down deep
your ear's abs no you did not you did
not see sweat trickling down anyone's
ABS because I've never seen sweat trickl
down my abs at all does DPR i/ Christian
want another dog oh my goodness I
already know where this is going to go
cuz I can bark wolf wolf [__] all right
my God this whole dog thing going whole
animalistic and wild I love it it it
seems like you're Untamed you're
definitely barking up the right
tree okay we need to talk about how much
Riz DPR Ian has like it's unbelievable
I'm so sorry what is RZ Charisma oh what
people call it Riz I knew that can we
edit that part out yeah people call me a
boomer this is the most flattering uh
tweet I think I've ever seen really
someone's thinks I have that much game
you think that about me I'm a true
introvert so I've always had trouble
even talking to someone that I had a
feeling for so I don't think I've ever
talked game before actually which is why
it's quite rather interesting this has
me thinking quite a lot I know I
shouldn't be so deep about these sweets
but I'm not sure if these are third
sweets anymore Riz learned something new
every day I had a dream we're Christian
you was my daddy and and sorry what um
he made me lick his boots then I woke up
in a cold sweat it sounds like a
terrible nightmare if you ask me and you
just wake up from a nightmare that
that's what usually happens when you
wake up from a nightmare you start
sweating or a fever dream it sounds like
a fever dream I made you lick my
boot uh I don't think I would ever do
that to anybody that's enough to make
anyone sick but thank you I would gladly
be your daddy you know in the beginning
I thought Daddy was actually like people
calling me Dad and I was so baffled but
now I get it these emoticons are getting
me what is that is that a tomato No it's
a red face and it's sweating or star
eyes and then you have spank me daddy
with an unusual crinkly face that sounds
like a whole experience that sounds like
me when I eat something spicy I just I
cannot um with a whole daddy thing I've
heard spank me before who hasn't I love
it you know but thank you I'll gladly
spank you oh my goodness I can't believe
I said that people think I'm actually
like this no I'm not like this am I
blushing am I getting red I think I feel
like I'm getting red deep in can choke
and step on me it sounds like we're an
MMA or something you know and then grab
my hair until I go bold and I'll still
be thankful for it if you're bold I
would never do that that sounds
terrifying if someone grabbed my hair
and then just ripped the living hair out
of me I'll be absolutely petrified is
this like legal like would to say all of
this I I think I'll pass on this one but
hey whatever rocks your world I'm here
for it next one it sounds so innocent oh
my God until you read the that's like a
little bit of jackn Heidi going on here
I would let dpan rearrange your guts
rearrange your guts and you have the
nice little star signs as if it's like
something that a fairy would say boy
it's getting more and more violent as we
go on ladies and gentlemen rearrange
your guts like how how would you
rearrange it why would you want to
rearrange your guts well let me think
really so everyone knows this you're
internally having your guts rearranged
why would you do that does that mean
like I'm make you like sick to the
stomach CU of how I guess hot someone is
I'm a little confused on this one I'm
going look it up a little bit later
hopefully
it's I shouldn't do that it's kind of
weird how everyone knows this Christian
you choke me marry me and kill me all of
the above now is it I feel like a
murderer at this point I feel like I'm
being investigated for something this is
quite terrifying first it's rearranged
someone's guts and then now it's like
I'm marrying you and killing you at the
same time I'll leave the killing part
out but okay oh okay this one's a little
bit better so apparently Christian you
smells sexy do I smell sexy I smell all
right can you say it again how it's R
yeah yes so apparently Christian new
smells oh like sex do oh my goodness
okay wait I see those are two totally
different meanings I'll still smell
myself I don't know I don't think I not
that I I'll leave it up to here um onto
the next Christian you was literally
having his breakfast and he turned me on
we can't be couple because I might die
from orgasms without having him touching
me like literally his visual can make me
wet was it always like this was all the
other third sweets like this I'm just
wondering this is quite graphic holy
moly macaroni this this is insane oh boy
I I feel like this is this so illegal
and I'm still rereading it uh I might
die just trying to get it oras without
having him touching me like literally
his V can make okay thank you I don't
know what what I was having for
breakfast but I'll think about that next
time I have breakfast Christian you you
owe my ovaries an apology I'm sorry to
your ovaries
I I would like to apologize I
hope I'll just stop here man it's
getting a little hot it's getting pretty
hot in here not sure if it's the studio
lights but it's it's getting pretty
insane oh goodness DPR Ian more like DPR
eat me now oh boy I know what that means
so I'm not going to reiterate this I
know what that means I will give you
eight points for creativity that's quite
that's a name I've never heard before DP
eat me now okay later wait no not later
what are you talking about goodness how
how many of these are there good morning
I just want to say that t in rail me
please sir rail
you um on to the next D in is probably
one of the few guys I'd let it hit it
whoo wo like Lord have Mery it says of
the th I don't know if that was
deliberate but it adds a lot to this
right now I don't care if I get Knocked
Up it'd be worth it let's let's make us
a little dreamer family I like how you
said dreamer family you're very
inclusive of that and you don't care if
you get knocked up I'm trying to um
remember what that means that means you
knocked up means getting pregnant it'd
be worth it oh dear hit it raw so okay
makes a lot of sense now that that means
you you probably get a high percentage
of getting pregnant I get it why was
that so hard to like but thank you who
is Christian you and why do I want to
pounce on his dick like pounce like a
cat or something on my dick why do you
want to do that counts deep deep here in
as if this was meant to be like a nice
letter I want to eat your thick two ass
sincerely me you want to eat my thick
ass oh boy how do you know it's thick
you want to eat my thick ass what are
you going to eat it with a spoon
someone's going to pounce on my dick
someone wants to eat my ass I'm getting
destroyed here Christian you would you
like to of course dick me down it's for
science hun why would that be for
science [__] someone down does that
mean something am I missing something
again usually people would say that when
they're resorting to something and
they're making an excuse for it but this
is pretty um direct I don't think you
need to excuse yourself with the science
I think that makes a little bit more
confusing just say you want to dig me
down I'm over it now I'm used to it now
I'm so numb I'm getting my ass eaten my
dick pounced if deep your ear needs a
hole he can use all
three then I'll pull apart the fs of
space to create new ones just for him wa
let me okay let me just let me just
really breathe this one in if D ear
needs a hole like a hole he can use all
three three what do you mean by that
this sounds more like a size question
I'll put apart the folds of space to
create new ones what do you mean by
three holes are you talking about the
holes on your
body no including the one on my bum I
think that's four so you're a little
wrong there I got four holes I got two
here one there no 1 2 3 4 5 six got six
holes what are you talking about I'll
pull apart the folder space to create
new ones like the folds in your body
just to create another hole to create
new ones just for him oh on you oh wait
sorry this isn't on me still we all have
two nostrils two earholes it's it still
applies to you at the same time oh to
create new ones no no you're fine with
the the the three holes no no please
don't do that that would be awkward I I
would hate to see a hole on your thigh
or something like that please three
holes is is plenty it's beautiful oh my
goodness I don't know why is it so hard
but thank you no need to do that dear my
gosh and that was it I cannot right now
this is insane man this was crazy wow
yes please
my hands are just like I'm frozen in
space right now how do I feel how does
everyone else feel right now I don't
think it's valid for me right now I
don't know how to feel I feel like I got
destroyed some somehow I feel pretty
weird but I'm flattered thank you so
much you know what it's like one of
those um it's like if people had these
thoughts you know those uh thoughts
running through your head and then it
just happened to end up on tweet that's
kind of what it feels like right now but
it's good it's good to know you guys are
very uh creative I'll give you that it's
kind of weird to promote something right
now
uh oh boy I'm so those were my first
suets uh here at BuzzFeed I am
absolutely burning up right now um make
sure to listen to Dear insanity if that
makes you horny too then I am completely
lost for
[Music]
words